bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat rapprocher la justice
des français c'est ainsi que nicolas
sarkozy a présenté le projet de loi
relatif à la mise en place de jurys
populaires
ce texte est examiné depuis hier par les
sénateurs
il prévoit l'association de citoyens au
fonctionnement de la justice pénale
actuellement les jurys populaires ne
siègent que dans les cours d'assises qui
jugent les crimes
l'opposition sénatoriale a déjà prévenu
qu'elle voterait contre un texte pour
les sénateurs socialistes nicolas
sarkozy considère les juges comme trop
laxiste il faut donc associer des
citoyens pour rendre une justice plus
juste
la commission des lois ici au sénat a
cependant réduit la portée de ce texte
elle propose en effet que la
participation des citoyens au
fonctionnement de la justice pénale ne
se fasse dans un premier temps que sous
forme d'expérimentation dans les cours
d'appel et ce jusqu'au 1er janvier 2014
avant un vote définitif du parlement
tout de suite donc et direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre le début de la
discussion des articles de ce texte très
bonne séance à tous nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi sur la
participation des citoyens au
fonctionnement de la justice pénale et
le jugement des mineurs
nous sommes parvenus à la motion numéro
155 pendante au renvoi à la commission
du texte en discussion et la parole et à
madame josiane mathon-poinat vous avez
la parole madame la sénatrice
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues on ne peut
engager de procédure accélérée pour un
texte qui modifie l'organisation
judiciaire de notre pays
on ne peut non plus exiger des
parlementaires un travail au rabais pour
un texte quelque peu brouillon et dont
le passage en force nous explique par
l'échéance présidentielle
nous venons d'être invité par la
commission de lois a visité plusieurs
établissements pénitentiaires pour
mineurs ainsi que des centres éducatifs
fermés dans le cadre du groupe de
travail sur l'évaluation de ces
établissements elles auront lieu le 23
et le 26 mai prochain et le bon sens
nous dicterait d'attendre les résultats
de ses travaux afin de durcir encore le
traitement pénal de la délinquance
juvénile
mais si ce texte avait été rédigé en
vertu de quelconques que sollicitation
du bon sens vous vous seriez vous même
étonné de sa précarité et de
l'impossibilité de sa mise en oeuvre
pour notre part ce qui nous étonnerait
aujourd'hui c'est que vous sachiez
préféré le bon sens aux impératifs de
communication qui guident certaines
stratégies de campagne
ce texte par et il entend faire en sorte
que justice soit rendue au nom du peuple
français
ceci alors que vous atteler depuis un
certain temps à mettre en place une
justice à deux vitesses et la flatterie
et bien h pour un peuple que le
président de la république dit écouter
mais ne pas tenir compte et la
manipulation sémantique est encore une
fois bien trop grossières pour passer
inaperçu car ni monsieur woerth si
madame bettencourt d' pourront être
jugés par des citoyens tirés au sort
puisque vous avez pris la précaution
d'exclure les délits économiques et
financiers du champ des délits concernés
le véritable enjeu en réalité de faire
en sorte que la justice soit faite pour
tous et non pas qu'elle soit fait par
tous seuls nous ne sommes évidemment pas
contre le fait que les citoyens soient
associés à l'élaboration des décisions
de justice
un système d'organisation judiciaire
dans lequel les affaires sont entendus
et jugés par des juridictions composé à
la fois de magistrats professionnels et
de personnes issues de la société civile
élu par des organisations
professionnelles et syndicales telles
que l'échevinage était une perspective
viable une réforme d'une telle ampleur
justifierait la mise en place d'un
certain nombre de modalités pratiques
comme prévoir du temps pour que les
citoyens aient connaissance des éléments
du dossier
or au regard du volume des affaires
traitées quotidiennement par les
tribunaux correctionnels et parce que
vous introduisez s'est juré avec la
seule ambition qui vous servent
contre-pouvoir au juge
jugée trop laxiste mais il n'en est rien
et le pende en direct du principe selon
laquelle la justice est rendue au nom du
peuple français et qui lui n est
sociable et celui d'égal accès à la
justice
est ce au nom d'une justice donc rendu
que vous avez supprimé ab terme en
tentant de tribehou nous rend pas encore
l'égal accès à la justice
faut-il rappeler qu'il y ait environ
neuf juges du siège pour 100000
habitants alors que la moyenne
européenne est de 21 à l'aune des
multiples réformes de la justice pénale
intervenus ces dernières années les
professionnels ne manquent pas d'outil
juridique répressif mais plutôt de
moyens pour faire correctement leur
métier et mettre à exécution les
décisions
bien que l'expérimentation soit
désormais possible dans le champ des
libertés publiques
il apparaît quelque peu surprenant
qu'une expérimentation interviennent
dans le domaine du de la justice on ne
peut pas envisager que dans quelques
tribunaux seulement la procédure et la
formation de jugement ne soit pas la
même que sur l'ensemble du territoire
il y a là une rupture d'égalité
flagrante passible d'une censure en
bonne et due forme du conseil
constitutionnel mais ceci dit malgré le
récent coup de semonce du conseil
constitutionnel qui vous a sagement
rappeler que le fait de gouverner
n'appliquez pas qu'on pouvait agir selon
ses caprices en réformant la justice des
mineurs
cependant vous vous entêtez le
toilettage superficielles apportées aux
dispositions censurées dans la loppsi ne
trompe personne
il s'agit bien de la fin de la
spécialisation de la procédure
applicable aux mineurs
l'ensemble des mesures que vous nous
proposez ne repose que sur des
déclarations ubuesque
et quelques autres assénées comme des
vérités selon lesquelles les mineurs
aujourd'hui ne seraient pas les mêmes
qu'en 1945 est certes c'était les
enfants de la guerre qui avait connu les
restrictions la violence chiffres à
l'appui comme à l'accoutumée vous tenté
de nous faire croire que la délinquance
des mineurs ne cesse d'augmenter et bien
entendu fidèle à vos stratégies de
communication il vous fallait trouver un
coupable et faire incarner la faute
c'était initialement la cause du laxisme
des parents tous considérés comme
démissionnaires voulait menacé alors de
supprimer leurs allocations familiales
que maintenant ce n'est même plus une
menace de les conduire à l'audience de
leurs enfants menotté et ensuite de les
surveiller à leur place avec mass
l'électronique mais c'est doublement la
faute de l'institution judiciaire qui
aura été de tout temps trop clémente
avec la jeunesse vous revenez donc sur
l'excusé de minorité
avant de désosser étape par étape
l'ordonance de 45
et là vous restez sourds aux cris des
larmes de l'ensemble des associations et
structures relatives à l'enfance qui ne
ce qui ne cesse de plaider pour que
cesse la mutilation de cette dite
ordonnance selon les chiffres exposés
par votre la ministre madame alliot
marie en fin d'année dernière pour
chauffer l'opinion à blanc sur la
réforme de la justice des mineurs
il y aurait deux cent quatre mille
mineurs qui ont été mises en cause pour
des faits graves inflation dans tout le
monde est responsable
excepté vous or il faut reconnaître que
le durcissement de la politique pénale
élargissement du filet pénales ont
clairement amplifier les critères de
définition des infractions existence
tout en aggravant les sanctions
et lorsqu on élargit la définition de la
délinquance et que l'on donne des
consignes visant à poursuivre toutes les
infractions même le plus bénignes cela a
nécessairement un effet inflationniste
sur le nombre de procès verbaux dressés
par les policiers et les gendarmes ont
la statistique policière est précisément
un comptage de ces procédures
administratives de plus une part non
négligeable des mis-en-cause débouche
sur des non lieux sur des classements
sans suite voir sur des relaxes
enfin le fait d'être mise en cause ne
traduit aucune notion de gravité on
l'aura compris mais ce type se manipule
aisément nous remarquons d'ailleurs que
lorsque la conjoncture où le temps
électoral vous l'imposent vous ne
manquez pas de vous féliciter de vos
prétendus résultats en matière de
sécurité
quoi qu'il en soit une réforme aussi
graves de la justice des mineurs aurait
nécessité un texte unique et non pas
quelques articles dans un projet de loi
censé démocratiser la sitution
judiciaire reconnaissait d'ailleurs
qu'il est quelque peu paradoxale quand
ex qu'entend faire participer les
citoyens à la justice marginalise les
assesseurs des tribunaux pour enfants
représentant la société civile qui
contribuent au bon fonctionnement de
cette justice la participation du juge
dans la nouvelle composition de la
formation du tribunal correctionnel pour
mineurs n'est qu'un écran de fumée pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que la
spécialisation du juge pour enfant tient
à la spécificité de son mode
d'intervention est dès lors le simple
fait qu'il soit présent de garantie
absolument pas la spécialisation du
tribunal de plus malgré vos efforts
monsieur le rapporteur qu'ils soient
prises dans la formation de jugement ne
constitue nullement une garantie puisque
ne disposera pas de voix prépondérante
en effet les magistrats effectué un
roulement au cours de leur tour de
service est un juge pour enfant peut en
tout état de cause se retrouver dans
n'importe quelle formation de jugement
s'il est sollicité au cours de ce tour
de service
cela n'a jamais emporté donc la
spécialisation du tribunal le tribunal
correctionnel pour mineurs ne répondons
pas à l'exigence constitutionnelle de
composition spécifique de la justice des
mineurs
compte tenu la surcharge actuelle des
audiences correctionnelles
les jeunes concernés ne bénéficieront
pas de l'examen attentif et complet de
leur personnalité et de leurs évolutions
auxquelles procèdent les juridictions
pour mineurs
or dans sa décision du 10 mars 2011 le
conseil constitutionnel a estimé que la
priorité éducative ne permettait pas de
généraliser des dispositions répressives
telles que l'application des peines
planchers aux mineurs
ce qui suppose de réelle investigation
sur la personnalité du mineur dans le
but de rechercher les moyens
réapproprier à l'orée du question ici
par le biais du dossier unique de
personnalité il pourra être jugées plus
rapidement les sa première infraction
lyon ainsi par le truchement des textes
et les manipulations malveillant de la
possibilité de présentation immédiate
il sera désormais possible de juger un
mineur le jour même de son déferrement
la comparution immédiate pour les
mineurs aussi censuré par le conseil
constitutionnel et donc réintroduite les
investigations préalables nécessaires
sur la personnalité du mineur ne seront
pas recueillies de même que ce fameux
dossier unique de personnalité pose tout
de même quelques problèmes majeurs
d'abord au regard des règles de
confidentialité strictes qui encadrent
l'accès aux pièces d'un dossier
d'assistance éducative mais aussi du
fait que les investigations menées au
civil concerne le mineur et tout ça fait
tri il s'agit là d'un réel danger qui
risque de favoriser des raisonnements
déterministe tel que celui qui aboutit à
la conclusion qu'on pouvait repérer un
délinquant des trois ans pour une
décision qui doit être prise pour un
individu
ensuite parce que rien ne justifie le
double contrôle de ce dossier par le
procureur de la république juste des
enfants la compétence du juge des
enfants est déterminé par la personne
même de l'enfant le juge des enfants le
seul apte à détenir les dossiers
concernant le mineur puisque en tant que
juge du siège
il est tenu par une procédure limitant
l'accès au dossier afin de protéger la
vie privée des enfants et des
collatéraux
vous entendez créer un signe justice des
mineurs bicéphale avec d'un côté le
parquet conduit les mesures prises dans
le cadre de la troisième voie soit la
moitié des procédures et qui reprendra
la main sur les mineurs les plus connus
de la justice et de l'autre un juge des
enfants neutralisaient et marginalisées
en matière pénale le juge des enfants
sera des saisies de fait les situations
les plus complexes qui requiert une
réponse adaptée et que justifie
l'importance de la phase pré sentenciel
ce qui est tout à fait inadmissible
vous l'avez donc compris nous estimant
que l'ensemble des dispositions de ce
texte relève dans leurs intellectuels
sans précédent pour un populisme bien
réel c'est la raison pour laquelle au
nom du peuple français je vous invite
et je vous demande mes chers collègues
parlementaires de renvoyer ce texte à
son examen
en commission je fournis merci josiane
mathon-poinat alors je rappelle mais je
vais demander tout d'abord la vie de
monsieur le rapporteur sur cette motion
merci monsieur président du président
celui ci reconnaît quelques éléments de
réponse madame mathon poinat sur cette
motion de renvoi en commission
donc d'abord pour dire s'ils voulaient
qu'il y ait toute une série de 2-2-2
jugement que je ne partage pas sur un
certain nombre de points qui m'intéresse
d'ailleurs la motion que de manière
accessoire vous parler par exemple de la
proximité de la justice je ne suis pas
tout à fait certain que la proximité de
la justice ça consiste à voir un
tribunal de l'autre côté de sa rue je
crois que la proximité de la justice
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
effectivement le fait d'avoir une
justice qui est rendue de manière à la
fois parfaitement cohérente et
relativement rapide
c'est moi un sénateur du nord je me
souviens de l'extrême brutalité de la
réforme de la carte judiciaire
dans mon département il y avait sept
tribunaux de grande instance
après cette réforme effectivement à la
hache il en reste aussi je crois
monsieur le ministre que ça permet
effectivement de préserver très
largement des impératifs de proximité de
même comment plaider sur
l'inconstitutionnalité de
l'expérimentation
alors que nous avons fait une réforme
constitutionnelle pour la rendre
possible
donc si les mots ont un sens bien
évidemment l'expérimentation on peut
penser qu'elle heurte notre tradition
juridique sur la rupture d'égalité
qu'elle va induire mais elle est
autorisée
elle a même été aménagé par notre texte
constitutionnel sur la situation des
mineurs délinquants moi je suis toujours
un peu surpris que l'on considère un peu
a priori que toute procédure
rapide est une procédure qu'il aurait
nécessairement défavorable je pense pas
qu'il soit absolument certain qu'il soit
bon effectivement pour un mineur en
situation de délinquance d'attendre 18
mois entre l'infraction et
l'intervention du tribunal correctionnel
et je vous parle même pas des cinq
années en dans l'hypothèse de crimes en
moyenne qui sépare effectivement
l'infraction de l'intervention de la
cour d'assises sur le problème plus
précis du renvoi en commission
je reprendrai les dispositions portant
soit délinquance des mineurs pour
reconnaître c'est vrai qu'une réforme
globale de l' ordonnance du 2 février 45
relative à l'enfance délinquante est
actuellement en cours d'élaboration mais
il ne paraît pas possible d'aboutir dans
les prochains mois un travail qui ne
peut être par hypothèse que complexe et
long or nous avons tous conscience de la
nécessité de mieux prendre en charge les
mineurs qui en ont le plus besoin
l'adoption des dispositions figurant
dans le présent projet de loi n'invalide
absolument pas le travail en cours dans
les services de la chancellerie
il ne fait qu'anticiper sur l'adoption
de plusieurs mesures ayant vocation à
figurer de toute façon dans un futur
code de la justice pénale des mineurs
je voudrais surtout attirer votre
attention sur le fait que plusieurs
dispositions du projet de loi ont fait
l'objet d'appréciations tout à fait
positive de la part des personnes que
j'ai entendu tel est notamment le cas du
dossier unique de personnalité qui a été
unanimement salué comme un instrument de
rationalisation des procédures au
service d'une meilleure prise en charge
du mineur tel est également le cas des
dispositions tendant à permettre à la
juridiction d'assortir une peine d'une
sanction éducative de la possibilité de
convertir plus largement une peine de
travail d'intérêt général dans le cadre
de l'aménagement de peine ou encore de
la possibilité de rendre un jugement
qualifié de contradictoire a signifié à
l'encontre des parents absents à
l'audience
je remarque d'ailleurs que sur certains
points aucun amendement de suppression
n'a été déposée c'est le cas de la
conversion des peines en travail
d'intérêt général ou de l'information de
la victime de la date de l'audience de
jugement par exemple
je constate également que sur les
investigations nécessaires sur la
personnalité du mineur
notre commission des lois a été
particulièrement vigilants pour ajouter
encore aux précautions qui avaient été
prises par le gouvernement pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons il ne paraît
pas utile de renvoyer le présent projet
de loi en commission et au nom de la
commission
j'aimais donc un avis défavorable à ce
renvoi en commission
merci jean rené lecerf fenassiers
ministre vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup c'est le président madame
battons pas la via de soutenir une
motion de renvoi en commission
or j'ai dans les mains un projet de loi
et qui est le texte de la commission qui
est bien la preuve que la commission a
largement un travail et doit dire qu' il
appartient probablement pas aux
exécutifs de s'immiscer dans les
relations entre l'assemblée et sa
commission
depuis ce que le président fischer me
demande mon avis je suis bien obligé de
dire que le travail fait par la
commission convient tout à fait aux
gouvernements et qu'elle est défavorable
arc la commission recommence un travail
qu'il considère comme étant globalement
bon avis défavorable alors nous avons
deux avis défavorables du rapporteur et
du gouvernement
je rappelle qu'en application du dernier
alinéa de l'article 44 du règlement ont
seul droit à la parole sur cette motion
bull auteur de la motion ceux
représentant la vue un orateur d'opinion
contraire il y en at il
il n'y en a pas et je rappelle qu'aucune
explication de vote n'est admise hier je
soumets cette motion l'approbation notre
assemblée qui est pour l'adopter
10 ce qui est contre elle n'est pas
adoptée
alors nous allons commencer l'examen des
articles et je suis saisi d'un
amendement 43 qui vise à insérer un
article additionnel lavande articles 1er
et je donne la parole à la présidente
nicole borvo cohen seat
merci monsieur le président alors voyez
préalablement à tout débat concernant
une réforme de la justice pénale visant
à élargir la participation des citoyens
aux tribunaux correctionnels
il nous sommes le très important de
revenir sur une disposition
normalement d'exception qui tendent à
devenir la norme c'est à dire les procès
en correctionnelle à juge unique puisque
ça va à l'encontre de ce que chacun
semble souhaiter ici la collégialité
nous semble-t-il est une garantie du bon
fonctionnement de la justice pour nos
concitoyens
alors que le projet de loi entend faire
participer deux citoyens assesseurs aux
côtés de trois magistrats lors des
procès en correctionnelle concernant les
atteintes à la personne on ne saurait
que s'étonner du maintien du jugement à
juge unique en correctionnelle
la rupture d'égalité face à la justice
devient abusives les citoyens amené à
comparaître en correctionnelle pourront
selon le cas être traduit devant un
tribunal à juge unique
un tribunal collégial composé de trois
magistrats un tribunal correctionnel
citoyen composé de trois magistrats et
deux citoyens assesseurs sans compter
les tribunaux correctionnels peau
mineurs en outre il paraît assez
incohérent de multiplier d'une part les
possibilités de recours à juge unique et
au nom d'une soi-disant efficacité de la
justice et surtout il faut bien le dire
afin de réaliser des économies
budgétaires et d'autre part de créer un
fonctionnement complexe coûteux et lourd
en ajoutant des citoyens assesseurs pour
certains débits ainsi le gouvernement
nous fait la preuve qu'il sait trouver
les moyens nécessaires quand ceux ci
peuvent servir un projet que nous
considérons comme incontestables mais
qui lui tient à coeur
alors qu' il ne saurait trouver les
moyens pour sortir du juge unique est
appliqué la collégialité sur laquelle
chacun ici a eu l'occasion de dire
qu'elle était souhaitable est préférable
en tout cas un juge unique donc je pense
que vous aurez à coeur de suivre mon
amendement
monsieur le rapporteur jeu le président
cet amendement vise effectivement à
supprimer la formation du tribunal
correctionnel statuant à juge unique
je rappelle que cette formation a été
instituée par une loi du 29 décembre
cette compétence du juge unique est
encadré très largement puisqu'il ne peut
prononcer de peine supérieure à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement il n'est pas compétent
si le prévenu est en détention
provisoire lors de sa comparution devant
le tribunal n'a pas compétence
si le prévenu est poursuivi selon la
procédure de comparution immédiate
la possibilité donnée au tribunal
correctionnel de situer à juge unique
constitue en outre une condition
indispensable pour éviter l'engorgement
des juridictions correctionnelles l'avis
de la commission est donc défavorable
monsieur le ministre je partage bien
entendu le sentiment du rapporteur je
veux simplement rappeler que chaque
année le juge unique rend à peu près
480000 indécision qui faudrait
naturellement créé un certain nombre de
postes
pour rendre la formation collégiale que
dans ce cas c'est une dépense nouvelle
est qu'il ya probablement une
disposition constitutionnelle qui fera
échec à l'amendement de mme borvo cohen
seat
plutôt que de l'invoquer je préfère dire
avis défavorable bien nous avons deux
avis défavorables de la commission et du
gouvernement jean pierre michel vous
avez la parole pour dire que nous sommes
très très favorable à l'amendement du
groupe communiste qui va dans le bon
sens puisque dans ce texte je dirais on
rajoute à la collégialité bon mais je
remarque c'est le garde des sceaux que
dans un texte précédent remporté par
notre excellent collègue monsieur
dutreil
vous avez fait tout le contraire puisque
vous avez rajouté encore aux unique vous
avez permis au parquet de prononcer des
peines tout seul alors que ce n'est pas
un juge c'est un magistrat
vous avez
augmenter le champ de l'ordonnancé
pénale et là vous opposé à la
suppression du juge unique donc c'est on
est dans l'incohérence la plus totale en
fait je les dirai qu'on fait n'importe
quoi non vous faites ce qu'on vous dit
de faire
est-ce que vos moyens budgétaires vous
permettent de faire donc nous voterons
cet amendement y at il d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
tes potes qui est pour adopter cet
amendement présenté par la présidente
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous commençons l'examen de
l'article 1er je suis saisi d'une
demande de parole de jean pierre michel
de nicole borvo-cohen de catherine tasca
et d'aliments boumédiene thiery
merci monsieur le président j'ai
président tout à l'heure un proxy
monsieur ne sert foudre à dessau qui ont
fait qu'ils ont cité mon nom
oui je suis favorable bien entendu à ce
que la justice ouvre qu'elles ne restent
pas entre soi que ce ne sont pas une
tour d'ivoire que ce soit pas une caste
de gens qui savent tout et que les
citoyens puissent participer à l'oeuvre
de justice qui est rendue en leur nom je
remarque d'ailleurs que déjà de nombreux
citoyens participent mais pas n'importe
comment et pas comme vous faites car
déjà dans le projet de loi
on voit bien lorsque vous dites
s'assurera que les décisions
juridictionnelles ne seront pas
déconnecter les évolutions de la société
je dirais que c'est gentil pour les
magistrats comme si aujourd'hui les us
était complètement déconnecté des
évolutions sociales comme s'il jugeait
n'importe comment
et s'il n'était pas au contraire tout à
fait dans la société
on l'aura d'ailleurs beaucoup reproché
notamment aux organisations syndicales
de magistrats
donc je dirais que oui oui mais c'est
d'une autre façon c'est peut-être
système original weyer des historiens
qui seront tirés au sort oui mais qui
participeront aux juridictions de façon
je dirais permanente pendant un certain
temps qu'ils connaîtront ce que c'est
qu'une juridiction qui connaîtront ce
que c'est qu'elle a que de juger qu
auront accès préalablement au dossier et
qu'ils ne seront pas ces espèces de
le citoyen arriver dans une saison qui
vont siéger huit jours par an seulement
tenez vous bien huit jours par an
seulement et encore grâce à la
commission des lois
pas dans les tribunaux correctionnels et
à la fois dans les juridictions
d'application des peines et c est pour
ces huit jours par an une procédure
absolument d'une lourdeur extraordinaire
extraordinaire ça pose quand même de
graves problèmes ça pose le problème de
leur formation
vous dites informations alors peut-être
qu'il ya un amendement je crois du
groupe centriste qui veut vous voilà qui
va vous permettre de ne pas tomber sous
les fourches du conseil constitutionnel
qui est je suppose emma le gouvernement
est vexant l'ancien président de groupe
et qui met formation car en effet le
conseil constitutionnel a proposé juste
de proximité avait jugé qu'ils devaient
être formés alors comment va-t-on de
former des gens qui vont siéger huit
jours par an huit jours consécutifs les
jours alternatif
on ne sait pas ensuite deuxième problème
le resserrement très curieusement il
prêtant serment haddock qui ne conduit
nulle part encore dans le pote de
mesures pénales ce n'est pas le serment
des magistrats professionnels
donc ils sont au dessous d'eux puisqu'il
peut être pas le même serment ce n'est
pas le serment qui est prévu déjà dans
l'arctique du code de procédure pénale
serment assez long et qui rappellent les
exigences des jurés par rapport à la
société par rapport aux inculpés par
rapport aux victimes
c'est un ferment très court aux serments
adopte alors nous dit-on évidemment
j'avais été trop long peut-être que ça
aurait pris trop de temps sur l'audience
correctionnelle
et puis enfin le problème qui se pose au
sud est de savoir mais on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure si notre
amendement ne tombe pas c'est comment
ses assesseurs sont
désigné alors il faut bien se rendre
compte tous ceux qui sont ici
mr le savent bien c'est la liste des
jurés d'assises dans toutes les mairies
au mois de juin
on tire au sort bon on enlève
quelques-uns et même si on ne devrait
pas peu importe en transmet une ellipse
de triple à la commission départementale
qui elle fait un tri objectifs par
rapport à la loi
et ces gens là peuvent être jurés
d'assises ab oui mais pour juger les
délits il faut être
il faut présenter beaucoup plus de
garanties qu pour lui aller creed capot
juger les crimes ont peut être tiré au
sort comme ça je dirais voilà mais pour
juger les délits absolument pas il faut
encore que parmi ceux là on fasse
l'objet d'une enquête pour savoir alors
quoi
ce n'est de bonne moralité si voilà tout
ça n'a aucun sens si ça a un sens le
sens et que votre procédure est
totalement boiteuse impraticable le vrai
sens si vous aviez voulu vraiment
c'était la récusation comme en cour
d'assises à mehdi le l'étude d'impact
fameuse étude d'impact qui n'étudient
rien du tout d'ailleurs
ça serait trop long et bien sûr ça
serait trop long ça serait trop long
calenge chaque affaire le l'avocat de la
défense où l'avocat de la victime ou le
procureur 10 annonce suit là non je
récuse parce que c'est une femme exige
une affaire de moeurs
parce que c'est un homme équipements
voilà on ne récuse pas mais on trie
alors on trie comment on garde les
notables en garde ceux qui sont bien en
enlève ce qui sans mal au nom de quels
critères
tout ça n'est pas sérieux monsieur le
ministre c'est une mauvaise loi une très
mauvaise loi et jeu direct par sept
textes et par la façon dont vous faîtes
vous gâcher totalement la grande idée
qui était selon moi
et selon certains de mes amis peut-être
pas tout ce que les citoyens puissent
participer plus nombreux mieux au
jugement rendu à l'oeuvre de justice
oui mais pas comme ça et en le faisant
de la sorte je crois que vrai
véritablement pour l'avenir vous
indiquez nous handicaper beaucoup cette
ouverture de la justice aux citoyens et
jean-pierre michel madame la présidente
le baron cohen seat vous avez la parole
merci monsieur président raymond propos
et voisins on va dire puisque évidemment
la question du mode de désignation de
vos citoyens assesseurs pose évidemment
des problèmes
il s'inspire dont deux des jurés
d'assises
mais sans tout à fait s'aligner sur ce
dernier notamment d'ailleurs vous l'avez
dit clairement pour des raison de la
lourdeur de la procédure
donc il faut aller vite tout en
rallongeant la procédure avec
l'introduction des assesseurs
ça pose un problème donc ses citoyens
tirés au sort sur les listes électorales
sont comme l'a dit jean pierre michel le
fruit d'une sorte de sélection opérée
par le maire qu'il abhorre un recueil
d'informations ils doivent prêter
serment mais pas de manière aussi
développé que les jurés cetera
une incohérence est particulièrement
notable bien évidemment c'est
l'impossibilité de récusation et c'est
de cela que je voudrais parler ses
citoyens assesseurs ne peuvent être
récusé que pour l'une des causes de
récusation applicables aux magistrats
parce que les citoyens ne choisissent
pas leurs jugé que les magistrats
professionnels présenter garantie de
leur indépendance et leur impartialité
et possibilité de les récuser sont
limitées très encadrée au contraire les
jurés d'assises simples citoyens tirés
au sort peuvent être récusés par la
défense et le ministère public comme des
bulles chaque affaire cela est
souhaitable en raison même de l'absence
de garanties a priori concernant
l'impartialité de ses citoyens tirés au
sort qui peuvent très bien être impliqué
de manière directe ou indirecte dans une
affaire ce qui pourrait influencer sur
leur jugement
ainsi loin de renforcer les liens entre
la justice et le peuple est d'augmenter
la légitimité démocratique de cette
justice dont vous ne cessé d'affirmer
qu'elle doit être rendue au nom du
peuple français ce qui est vrai
d'ailleurs elle est rendue au nom du
peuple français
quoi qu'il en soit vous allez au
contraire créer un climat de suspicion
en favorisant une défiance envers les
décisions rendues
ainsi que des contestations sur la
nouvelle institution elle même ce n'est
pas en introduisant un système mix de
tirage au sort sélection en amont que le
problème sera résolu bien au contraire
car ce faisant ils entérinent des
critères qu'on pourrait qualifier de
subjectif ou autre ou autre et allianz
une subjectivité ou de partialité et de
partialité je vais guiraud se demande
bien comment ce nouveau dispositif censé
réaffirmé l'importance du peuple saura
davantage donner confiance en la justice
merci présidente la parole que la
présidente catherine tasca
merci monsieur le président au moment où
nous abordons l'article 1er je veux
revenir sur l'introduction des jurés
populaires à plusieurs stades de la
procédure pénale
cette proposition du gouvernement pour
toute réponse à l'état de faiblesse de
la justice en france est un nouvel acte
de défiance à l'égard des magistrats
malgré vos dénégations
monsieur le garde des sceaux ce projet
de loi est la traduction législative de
la campagne politique de mise en cause
systématique du travail des magistrats
le président de la république toujours
prompt à rejeter un sur d'autres la
responsabilité de ses propres échecs à
distiller dans l'opinion l'idée à la
faveur de plusieurs faits divers que les
magistrats par leurs décisions agirait
contre la volonté des français en
matière de sécurité publique et que tout
irait mieux avec des jurés citoyens
je souhaite revenir sur les quatre
principaux points qui explique notre
refus de ce dispositif
d'abord la complexité du dispositif aux
termes du projet de loi deux citoyens
assesseurs tirés au sort sur les listes
électorales siègerait pour une semaine
au côté les trois magistrats
professionnels qui composent les
tribunaux correctionnels
ce service judiciaire obligatoire de
huit jours
elle n'est demandée ni par les
magistrats ni par les justiciables
ils ont pourtant en commun de subir en
première ligne la dégradation du service
public de
justice ce dispositif créera des
difficultés matérielles majeurs dont le
gouvernement semble vouloir se délester
sur les magistrats et sur les élus
locaux
ainsi les maires auront pour charge
d'adresser aux personnes tirées au sort
sur les listes électorales un recueil
d'accusation une commission sur la base
de ses recueils qu'elle devra traiter
dressera la liste annuelle des citoyens
assesseurs pour chaque tribunal de
grande instance la justice française
d'ores et déjà en gang au rejet at elle
besoin qu'on lui impose de nouvelles
lourdeurs administratives
quant à la charge financière
l'indemnisation de quelques 8000
citoyens assesseurs rappeler chaque
année nécessitera des moyens financiers
conséquents évaluée à plus de 20
millions d'euros
l'institution judiciaire déjà exemple au
point qu'elle a des difficultés à payer
les jurys d'assises et les juges de
proximité
le budget du ministère de la justice qui
par sa faiblesse classe la france au 35e
37e rang européen
tout cela n'est pas sérieux la
dégradation aussi des conditions de
jugement
l'introduction de citoyens assesseurs
contribuera à dégrader un peu plus les
conditions du jugement
ces citoyens novice en droit devront
prendre connaissance de l'intégralité
des éléments des dossiers les délais des
jugements des jalons du fait de
l'encombrement des tribunaux seront
allongés le risque d'une paralysie du
système est réel au détriment des
personnes jugées des victimes
je vous renvoie aux propos de monsieur
garraud secrétaire national de l'ump en
charge de la justice
le gouvernement a aussi choisi de
réserver à certains délits la présence
de citoyens assesseurs sans d'ailleurs
que l'on connaisse les critères qui ont
présidé à cette sélection
la commission a certes ajouter les
infractions au code de l'environnement
également passibles d'une peine égale ou
supérieure à cinq ans alors que celles
ci sont souvent d'une grande technicité
et nécessite une expertise juridique qui
touchent aussi bien en droit de
l'environnement qu'au droit
international et au droit européen
les affaires liées à la délinquance en
col blanc n'ont étonnamment pas été
retenu comment justifier que les
citoyens assesseurs pour présenter comme
une panacée par le gouvernement en
soient tenus à distance
enfin la question de la
constitutionnalité du dispositif
le projet de loi crée une justice à deux
vitesses mais ceux ci étaient bien
expliquent bien exposé dans l'émotion
procédure nul doute que le conseil
constitutionnel serait amené à se
prononcer sur la conformité à la
constitution de mesures qui portent
atteinte à l'égalité entre les citoyens
et à l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire
cela a été dit les français attendent de
l'institution judiciaire qu'elle assure
un traitement égal des citoyens devant
la loi quelle soit rendue dans des
délais raisonnables et que les décisions
de justice soient rapidement mises à
exécution ce texte va à rebours de ces
trois objectifs
tout cela nous l'avons 10 apparemment
sans vous convaincre encore je tenais à
le rappeler pour conclure je formule
formulerait un grief supplémentaire
allait à l'encontre de ce texte
nul ne peut ignorer aujourd'hui
l'évolution de notre société et la part
démesurée mais malheureusement
incontournable de la communication et
des médias dans l'information et des
informations de nos concitoyens dès lors
comment peut-on croire que la présence
de jurés citoyens
extrait de chez eux peut être à contre
coeur ignorant le droit apportera une
réelle plus value au travail des
magistrats
au mieux ils seront dépendants des
magistrats au pire ils seront dépendants
des médias et ne sauront exprimé qu'un
état de l'opinion telle qu'elle peut
être saisi dans l'instant on ne peut
juger dans le sentiment ni le
ressentiment l'application de la loi
doit rester notre commune garantie de
justice et de liberté
c'est un métier comme l'a si bien dit
notre collègue jacques mézard le citoyen
attend non de rendre la justice mais que
justice lui soit rendue
ça n'est vraiment pas la voie que vous
empruntez c'est pourquoi nous
demanderons la suppression de l'article
1er merci président
et cette alima boumédiene thiery qui a
la parole sur cet article premier
président en effet il est important pour
nous de dire cet article 1er nous semble
ouvertement provocateur à l'égard des
magistrats professionnels par
l'instauration de citoyens assesseurs au
sein des travaux correctionnelle et des
tribunaux d'application des peines le
gouvernement ne met en place qu'un
mécanisme attentatoire au bon
fonctionnement de la justice qui sèment
la suspicion
vous prétendez monsieur le garde des
sceaux vouloir restituer la justice au
peuple et pour ce faire vous souhaitez
associer aux magistrats professionnels
des citoyens assesseurs
cette participation des citoyens ne nous
paraît pas fondée
en effet ce que vous tentez de mettre en
place ne va que ralentir de manière
considérable une justice française déjà
à l'agonie par votre faute vous associer
à des professionnels et citoyens qui ne
comprennent ne connaîtront rien ni de la
subtilité du droit ni de la complexité
des éléments constitutifs du délit
l'alinéa 44 de l'article 1er vous
avancez comme principal argument
l'intégrité des citoyens assesseurs et
le fait qu'ils auront prêté le serment
de bien et fidèlement remplir leur
fonction est de conserver le secret des
délibérations
c'est tout simplement grotesque car rien
ne prouve que ce serment leur permettra
de faire preuve d'une impartialité
nécessaires à cette fonction tout porte
à croire que vous cherchez monsieur le
ministre à défier les magistrats à
l'alinéa 51 de cet article vous soulever
un problème auquel vous ne répondez pas
celui de la formation de ses citoyens
assesseurs
selon le texte un décret en conseil
d'état fixera les modalités
tout ceci est fort obscur et ne lâche
rien pressage et présage le bout comme
j'ai pu le demander tout à l'heure en
discussion générale
le contenu de cette formation doit être
clairement énoncé et surtout répondre
aux besoins liés à ce nouveau statut
ce dernier doit pouvoir faire preuve de
la mesure et du discernement nécessaire
pour mener à bien ce devoir civique
comme vous plaisait à le souligner l
né à 49 de cette même article enfin un
dernier aspect de cet article reste en
suspens il concerne la façon dont le
gouvernement compte s'assurer de la
présence de ces jurés populaires au
procès correctionnel vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir monsieur le ministre
combien il est déjà difficile de
constituer un jury en cour d'assises
vous semblez penser que tous les
citoyens désignés se précipiteront afin
d'effectuer cette mission huit jours par
an en tribunaux correctionnels
comme dans les tribunaux de
l'application des peines mais vous vous
leurrer et vous rencontrerez les mêmes
difficultés quant à 6 accentuée par un
système de dispense fort compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre
ainsi il reste bien des points à éluder
bien des zones d'ombré dans ce projet de
loi insipide qui relève en effet du
populisme judiciaire
il nous faut des réponses précises afin
de ne pas mettre en place de nouveaux
mécanismes qui ne feront que ralentir
l'appareil judiciaire et c'est donc dans
l'intérêt de la justice pénale que nous
ne pouvons pas accepter cet article et
que nous allons nous y opposer
formellement
merci nous avons terminé intervention
sur article nous passons à l'examen de
trois amendements identiques trois
amendements de suppression qui nous
présente l'amendement numéro trois c'est
alain anziani il monsieur le président
faites un moment effectivement a pour
but de supprimer
sertic cet article le premier donc la
création de ces fameux jouets citoyens
nous voulons la suppression pour trois
raisons la première elle est simple
c'est que cet article se fonde sur une
ambiguïté
depuis le début de l'après midi on nous
explique vous monsieur le garde des
sceaux monsieur le rapporteur que ces
jurés citoyens n'ont strictement rien à
voir avec la sévérité ou le laxisme dans
les décisions
c'est ce qu'on nous explique mais ça ce
sont les motifs écrits de la loire mais
il y a un motif orale qui me paraît
beaucoup plus fort le motif orale il
nous a été délivré le par le président
de la république le 31 décembre dernier
et où pris dans la république nous dit
avec
sa vigueur habituel qu'il veut protéger
les français de la violence chaque jour
plus brutale de la part des délinquants
multiréitérants et comment va-t-il le
faire et bien en ouvrons nos tribunaux
correctionnels aux jurés populaires
s'est ainsi le peuple qui pourra donner
son avis sur la sévérité de la réponse à
apporter à des comportements qui
provoquent l'exaspération du pays alors
il faut se mettre d'accord entre vous si
vous me permettez l'expression
est ce que il s'agit d'augmenter la
sévérité et donc de considérer que les
jurés les juges professionnels ne le
sont pas suffisamment sévères ou bien
est-ce qu'il s'agit d'autre chose nous
ne savons toujours pas moi je crois
plutôt à la parole du président de la
république il me semble que en la
matière elle mérite d'être entendue
alors je crois à la parole sauf que le
présent la république comme il lui
arrive quand même de temps en temps fait
une erreur d'appréciation magnifique
c'est d'ailleurs l'embarras dans lequel
vous vous trouvez car vous savez que sa
position
au fond elle n'est pas cohérent pourquoi
parce que rien ne nous montre vous
l'avez d'ailleurs indiqué vous même et
dans vos études d'impact vous le
soulignez rien nous montrent que les non
magistrats sont moins sévères en tout
cas elles ne sont pas moins sévère que
dans d'autres pays et une rapport du
conseil de l'europe qui nous demandent
une façon très nette une comparaison des
décisions dans les différents pays
rien ne nous montrent que les jurés
populaires seront plus sévères ça c'est
le premier point deuxième critique c'est
que madame tasca vient le rappeler juger
est un métier
enfin quoi d'un côté nous aurions des
gens qui passent un concours qui ont
quatre à cinq ans d'études
universitaires 31 mois de formation de
la formation continue et puis de l'autre
côté bien on a ceux qui viennent d'être
tirées au sort qui a ensuite apprend
fait l'objet d'une désignation et qui
viennent là et qui vont finalement
s'opposer qui vont donner leur point de
vue sans nécessairement avoir tout la
qualification
vous me direz oui une formation d'une
journée une journée de formation et bien
ça donne le poil autorités la
qualification pour discuter de ces
questions qui sont tout à fait difficile
dernier point le dernier point c'est
quand même un paradoxe sur lequel vous
pas beaucoup vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
appesanti votre texte à quand même ce
cet effet magique de chasser un citoyen
par un hôte
oui il y avait des citoyens qui étaient
présents dans les chambres de
l'application des peines
des meubles des citoyens qui ont une
qualité qui ont une connaissance on sait
que il se représente soit les victimes
soient l'insertion
ils sont compétents et voulait remplacé
par keith et citoyens compétents et
qualifiés et bien vous les remplacer par
des citoyens qui n'ont pas de
qualifications et qui n'ont pas
manifesté un intérêt particulier pour
ces questions si alors le 44 c'est la
présidente nicole borvo cohen seat
merci monsieur le président eh bien il
s'agit effectivement de supprimer cet
article pour les raisons que j'ai
exprimés et dans mon intervention
général et dans l'intervention sur
article que je viens de faire qui tient
à la fois à l'objectif poursuivi bien
évidemment qui tient au mode de
désignation et qui tient le difficile
applicabilité de ce dispositif et
d'utilité qui semble effectivement des
voiliers puisque de jus rennes 2
j'aurai deux assesseurs citoyens aux
citoyens assesseurs je ne sais plus qui
ne sont pas vraiment qu'ils ne forment
pas jury que vont ils apporter si ce
n'est ce qu'attend effectivement on va
dire le président de la république
puisque c'est lui qui au fond a lancé la
réforme
votre réforme mais si vous voulez je
voulais donc évidemment pour ces raisons
vous l'aurez bien compris on demande de
revenir sur ce dispositif mais
entendons-nous bien parce que là nous
n'avons pas de réponse à cela on va
poser la question pourtant mais on n'a
pas de réponse
la participation des citoyens à la
justice et pour notre part une bonne
chose mais par contre elle ne doit pas
se faire dans n'importe quelles
conditions
nous sommes favorables je le dis encore
une fois un système d'échevinage qui
prennent modèle ou qui s'inspire des
assesseurs des tribunaux pour enfants ou
encore des prud'hommes ces citoyens sont
alors volontaire et surtout retenu pour
leurs qualités leurs compétences
professionnelles je dirais leur intérêt
à la justice dans tel ou tel domaine où
ils sont des personnalités
d'associations qui sont en lien direct
avec les problèmes que traite la
juridiction
alors ça c'était assez intéressant et on
voit que ça une grande utilité alors
comme disait notre collègue vous voulez
chasser par exemple les
et représentants d'associations de
victimes me voulait supprimer justement
mais plus globalement pourquoi ne pas
avoir choisi ce dispositif qui a fait
ses preuves et au contraire entrer dans
quelque chose qui est assez
contre-productif en quelque sorte qu'ils
aient des jurés tirés au sort qui en
fait ne seront pas des jurés et qui donc
on peut le penser n'apporteront rien
sinon peut-être brouilleront ni les
comment dire les jugements en matière de
correctionnelle donc là dessus vous nous
avez vous savez très bien qu'il ya la
méthode d'échevinage et la méthode
tirage au sort nous avait dit on a
choisi la méthode du tirage au sort mais
vous nous avez pas du tout expliqué
pourquoi alors est ce que ces raisons
d'économie bon je crois pas que ça coûte
plus cher est-ce que c'est justement
parce que ça ne correspond pas et je
crois que c'est bien ça la réponse à ce
que vous attendez de la présence de ces
deux personnes qui arriveront pour huit
jours dans un tribunal correctionnel
merci jacques mézard vous nous présentez
l'amendement 91 rectifier merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
c'est effectivement un amendement de
suppression le premier il y en aura une
longue liste parce que nous considérons
nous que tout est à supprimer
pratiquement dans ce projet de loi nous
l'avons exprimée je crois effectivement
qu'il faut être cohérent avec ses
positions alors monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure vous nous avez peu
répondu en fait sauf par des artifices
oratoire dans lesquelles vous excellez
en ce qui concerne
ce sera difficile monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie de ce compliment qui me
va droit au coeur
en tout cas déjà sur l'urgence vous nous
avez donné une seule réponse c'était
dans le programme du président de la
république alors il vous reste peu de
temps pour accomplir tout le programme
du président de la république en
particulier travailler plus pour gagner
plus entre autres mais il y en ad'autres
je peux vous en faire une soeur une
longue liste
on sait tous ici qu'il n'y a aucune
justification sérieuse si ce n'est une
opération de communication
quant aux objectifs et puis il ya eu
aussi une absence totale de concertation
nous avons tous entendu les
représentants professionnels ils nous
ont dit quoi on a vu très rapidement au
mois de décembre
la chancellerie il n'y a eu strictement
aucune concertation
et quant à la cadence à laquelle ce
dossier a été mené dans le débat
parlementaire
on peut pas non plus parler de
concertation même si nous reconnaissons
que le rapporteur comme à son habitude a
fait le maximum de ce qu'il pouvait
faire
dans le minimum de temps alors les
objectifs
il faudrait les connaître il faudrait
que vous laisse dizier une bonne foi est
ce que c'est la sévérité
est-ce que c'est ravel et pnb oui mais
alors vous êtes en contradiction avec le
président de la république vous êtes
aussi monsieur le ministre en
contradiction avec l'étude d'impact
puisque dans l'étude d'impact il est dit
qu'il faut éviter une érosion de la
peine pour des délits graves
c'est marqué dedans et j'avais cas pas
le lire je vois que vous avez une
opinion du travail parlementaire qui
comme révélatrice bon
deuxièmement donc c'est pas si je vous
entends bien c'est pas l'aggravation des
peines
il faut dire que heureusement puisque
nous avons appris aujourd'hui qu'il ya
soixante quatre mille personnes dans les
prisons françaises et quand on est en
train de rebattre les records
deuxièmement s'agit-il d'accélérer le
cours de la justice
nous avons tous eu la démonstration ce
soir que c'était le meilleur moyen pour
la freiner pour la freiner donc vous
avez vous nous dites que vous
vous avouez que le but c'est de freiner
le cours de la justice et de prendre
plus de temps dont acte ce sera au
journal officiel
troisièmement s'agit-il de diminuer le
coot de la jus de ces procédures non
nous savons tous que c'est inverse et
que ça va coûter plus cher c'est aussi
dans l'étude d'impact donc quant à vos
objectifs on peut pas dire quand même
qu'il soit merveilleux par rapport à un
meilleur fonctionnement de la justice
ça justifie pleinement la suppression de
cet article heures voilà trois
amendements de suppression quel est
l'avis de monsieur le rapporteur francs
le même commentaire sur les trois
amendements si vous le permettez
monsieur le président c'est trois
amendements visent donc à supprimer
l'article 1er lequel définit pour
l'essentiel les modalités de désignation
des citoyens assesseurs l'institution
deux citoyens assesseurs constitue un
des volets essentiels de la réforme
proposée par le projet de loi dans son
principe la participation des citoyens
aux juridictions pénales n'a pas suscité
d'opposition de la part des
interlocuteurs que j'ai rencontrés au
cours des auditions elle peut se
prévaloir je dis bien dans son principe
elle peut se prévaloir de l'expérience
des jurés dont les présidents de cours
d'assises nous ont tous indiqué qu'elle
était très fructueuse tant pour les
citoyens que pour les magistrats
c'est à dire quelques difficultés à
comprendre comment on peut être à la
fois obstinément favorable jurait et
obstinément défavorable citoyens
assesseurs puisque il ya malgré tout une
certaine filiation entre les
responsabilités des uns et les
responsabilités des autres je ferai
également observé que les critiques se
sont plutôt cristallisée sur quatre
aspects le mode de désignation des
citoyens assesseurs le rôle qui leur
seraient confiées pour les jugements des
délits et notamment les catégories de
délits qu'ils auraient été a confié la
substitution des citoyens assesseurs aux
jurés pour la formation des cours
d'assises dans leur composition
simplifiée et enfin bien sûr la question
des moyens nécessaires à la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme
et bien pour les trois premiers points
sur les moyens c'est plus compliqué la
commission a cherché dans le texte
qu'elles vous soumet à apporter des
améliorations qui permettent de lever
beaucoup de critiques
il reste effectivement le choix
tre les échevins et puis les citoyens
assesseurs les échevins et les jurés
c'est un choix difficile c'est
visiblement le gouvernement a penché sur
le citoyen assesseur plutôt que sur les
villages j'avoue que la la la réflexion
était effectivement ouverte il y a des
avantages et des inconvénients
dans chaque solution mais je m'étonne
que personne par exemple ne se pose la
question de la présence d'associations
de victimes dans le cadre de
l'application des peines j'ai énormément
de respect pour les associations de
victimes qui savent prendre une auteur
remarquable dans les prises de positions
qui sont les leurs mais est ce que
réellement c'est leur place de siéger au
niveau de l'application des peines moi
j'avoue que la question - je me la pose
bien sûr l'avis est défavorable sur les
trois amendements de ses ministres le
président et quelques mots pour répondre
aux orateurs qui a soutenu les
amendements de suppression
je voudrais d'abord dire que depuis que
j'ai été nommé je n'ai jamais eu un seul
mot mettant en doute la capacité des
magistrats la difficulté de leur travail
et la façon dont il rendait la justice
si un de vous peut apporter une phrase
que j'aurais prononcer l'instant ce
qu'il le fasse pas une seule fois au
cours de raids j'ai toujours veillé à
apporter le soutien de la chancellerie
et du ministre aux magistrats donc je
n'accepte pas l'argument selon
lesquelles il s'agirait de mettre en
doute la capacité des magistrats a bien
jugé
parce que jamais je n'ai mise en doute
leur capacité jamais et j'aimerais
commet des actes comme c'est moi qui
suis si madame je vous demande de me
donner acte et de cesser de m'opposer
sens c'est cet argument qui est un
argument faux etc
moi j'accepte tous les arguments dans ce
débat mais j'accepte tous les arguments
le débat à condition que sur des
arguments vrai et je n'ai pas pour ma
part le moindre problème avec les
citoyens j'ai entendu monsieur diali
qu'il dit mais comment on va mettre des
citoyens de simples citoyens en fait moi
je me revendique simple citoyen
comme beaucoup d'autres français et je
dis pas qu'il faut avoir 5 ans d'études
pour pouvoir être juge alors qu'on n'a
jamais demandé à un seul membre d'un
jury d'assises d'avoir fait cinq ans
d'études
je crois qu'il faut aussi avoir dans ce
pays
une considération pour les simples
citoyens il ya des relents de monarchie
juillet il faudrait avoir des capacités
pour pouvoir participer à l'oeuvre de
justice non le but poursuivi
ce n'est en aucun cas aggraver les
peines
je n'ai dit redit je le redis encore les
magistrats ne sont pas laxistes ils
appliquent la loi telle qu'elle est
votée et c'est vrai que nous avons
beaucoup de personnes condamnées ce
n'est pas du tout se sait pas aggraver
la peine
au contraire les jurés citoyens des
assesseurs auront plutôt une vision
autre et on ne recherche pas
l'aggravation tous les cas le
gouvernement ne recherche pas
l'aggravation de la peine ils
recherchent une seule chose dans notre
société on n'a pas très souvent
l'occasion d'exercer sa capacité de
citoyenneté et il s'agit avant tout et
d'abord d'exercer les fonctions de
citoyenneté en faisant participer des
citoyens au jugement des délits les plus
graves
c'est tout mais c'est énorme c'est
énorme parce que dans notre vie sociale
on a de moins en moins une occasion de
faire voir qu'on est des citoyens de
montrer cette capacité à participer à la
vie en commun et c'est là le but
poursuivi par ce texte c'est ce qui
explique qu'on fasse tourner les
citoyens pour qu'il y ait le plus grand
nombre possible qui participent à cette
oeuvre
on peut ne pas être d'accord ça je le
conçois parfaitement mais je ne pense
pas qu'il faille transformer les buts
poursuivis par ceux qui sont l'auteur du
projet eau peut le condamner on peut
être contre ça fait partie du débat et
je n'accepte fort bien mais je veux pas
que dans transforme le but poursuivi
alors c'est vrai que ça va coûter plus
cher
c'est tout à fait vrai c'est vrai ça va
être plus long parce qu'il y aura des
assesseurs citoyens présents qu'il
faudra expliquer plus qui aura un débat
et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que le
premier ministre à accepter qu'elles ont
créé des moyens je dis pas qu'ils seront
suffisants et s'ils ont recours à
l'expérimentation c'est pour voir s 6 et
boya sont suffisants si ça fonctionne
correctement s'il y a lieu d'apporter un
certain nombre de modifications avant la
généralisation de la mesure en 2014 et
que l'on essaye dans une société où les
citoyens vivent de plus en plus les uns
à côté des autres et de moins en mois
ensemble de trouver des occasions de
citoyenneté c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est tout à fait nécessaire a
calé on peut tous participé en
critiquant les modalités d'essayer
d'améliorer les choses et je les dis et
redis moi je suis prêt à entendre
beaucoup de choses et je veux pas
entendre que j'ai critiqué les
magistrats parce que c'est faux je ne
l'aï jamais fait et que je n'ai pas pour
objectif de faire participer les
citoyens à la vie citoyenne c'est tout
voilà alors nous avons deux avis
défavorables du rapporteur et du
ministre kherif que l'on bat jean pierre
michel virginie klès et alain anziani
ce président est monsieur ministre
appelle je voudrais tenter de répondre à
l'interrogation de notre éminent
collègue rapporteur qui ne qui dit ne
pas comprendre qu' on puisse être
favorable au jury ou jurés est
défavorable aux citoyens assesseurs
je constate que lui comprend très bien
la différence puisque grâce à lui on a
un amendement qui modifie ce que
prévoyait la loi initialement
s'agissant précisément des jurés la
composition des jurys d'assises
premier point deuxième point
si on revient aux principes il la
justice donc dans l'autre pays et dans
les pays démocratiques et est rendue au
nom du peuple français mais selon deux
modalités
une modalité que j'allais dire très très
ancienne et quasi religieuse tout le
monde est en citoyen tout le monde peut
juger tout le monde fait partie d'un
jury avec des procédures d'élimination
mais qui sont faites par essentiellement
par les défenseurs on ne sait pas de
sélection vraiment en effet pas passé
comme notre jurés assesseurs devant une
commission avec un paragraphe avec un
alinéa assez bizarre où il est dit que
la commission va voir s'ils ont les
capacités de remplir leur mission
ça c'est la première chose il deuxième
modalités de désignation
on rend justice au nom du peuple
français mais selon une autre filière ce
sont des magistrats professionnels qui
passent des examens qui sont désignés et
c est au nom donc toujours du peuple
français
là on a quelque chose d'intermédiaire on
a une variété tout à fait intermédiaire
c'est ça que nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi cette nouveauté et je crois que
le problème qui se pose à nous ou trop
ce qui a été souligné concernant la
lourdeur de la procédure enfin et c est
bien c'est que en croyant ou en faisant
semblant de croire qu'on va ajouter des
avantages on va prendre ce qu'il ya de
mieux dans chacun des systèmes viens on
va ajouter des inconvénients
donc le problème il est il est très
simple si on veut que des citoyens
participent à l'administration de la
justice
eh bien on prend des citoyens on ne leur
fait pas passé d'examen
si on ne veut pas en tout cas pour les
délits qui sont donc moins graves
au moins sur le papier en tout cas que
des crimes vient on se confie la mission
d un des juges professionnels
c'est ça donc c'est ce mélange que nous
ne comprenons pas jean pierre michel
merci monsieur le président c'est pour
dire monsieur le garde des sceaux que je
ne comprends pas pourquoi il a l'air de
croire qu'on le met en cause
personnellement et monsieur le ministre
vous êtes là c'est vrai c'est bien
d'ailleurs si bien qu on n y est pas un
secrétaires d'état comme le mini du
travail qui nous avons une secrétaire
d'état qui ne connaît rien au texte et
que vous connaissiez vos textes et que
vous soyez à responsabilité pour
répondre et vous êtes membre du
gouvernement
vous êtes solidaires de ce gouvernement
ce que vous dite personnellement ne nous
intéresse pas nous vous connaissant donc
en laissant vos idées de les en votre
personne
mais tout ça n'a aucun intérêt dans le
débat la seule chose qu'elle est allée
d'un débat c'est ce que dit le prévenu
république et le gouvernement ont le
texte qui est présenté malheureusement
pour vous c'est écrit dans l'exposé des
motifs
c'est écrit dans l'étude expat le plan
de la république l'a répété le ministre
de l'intérieur de l'époque l'a dit et
redit
vous êtes solidaires de ces paroles là
et si ça ne vous plaît pas excusez moi
monsieur le ministre faut tirer les
conséquences bien gêné claisse
oui merci monsieur le président quel
quelques remarques questions ou
réflexion tout d'abord à notre
rapporteur qui se pose la question de la
place des associations de victimes en
matière d'application des peines
oui bien sûr qu'elles avaient leur place
puisqu'il y avait un équilibre avec les
associations d'insertion
donc oui évidemment il y avait un
équilibre elles avaient toute leur place
ensuite en ce qui concerne les principes
de la constitution des jurys qui inclut
des citoyens oui nous sommes pour jamais
nous avons dit que nous étions contre ce
qui nous pose question aujourd'hui c'est
la façon et le calendrier dont sont
amenés ces textes et ces modifications
profondes ce qui reste un problème
aujourd'hui c'est l'objectif de ce
projet de loi on n'a toujours pas de
réponse monsieur le ministre excusez moi
mais je n'ai toujours pas entendu de
réponse quels sont les objectifs précis
de ce projet de loi le principe ne peut
se concevoir que s'il sert un objectif
précis concrets et compris par tous et
par chacun enfin monsieur le ministre à
propos des cinq ans d'études
c'est pas moi ni mon groupe qui tout à
leur avons pris un exemple nous sommes
abrités derrière un étudiant de 24 ans
interviewé par libération qui était
d'accord et même très heureux participe
au jury citoyen vous avez entendu 24 en
tout cas les cinq ans d'études y était
alain anziani
oui monsieur le garde des sceaux à
plusieurs reprises nous avait demandé de
vous donner à que vous ne mettiez pas en
causes les magistrats écoutez je crois
qu'effectivement nous pouvons vous
donner acte que vous ne mettez pas en
cause les magistrats
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on constate
qu'il ya une crise dans la magistrature
on constate que les magistrats et que
l'institution judiciaire se considère
comme aujourd'hui méprisés par le
pouvoir en place
on constate que ici et là il ya un sens
nombre de mouvements qui protestent
contre le sort qui leur est fait
pourquoi parce que à votre tour monsieur
le garde des sceaux
vous devez nous donner à que d'autres
choses nous donner à que le présent de
la république et je prends mon
expression de cet après-midi en traitant
les magistrats de petits pois il met en
cause la magistrature et l'institution
judiciaire que
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
hortefeux lorsqu'il met en cause une
décision d'un tribunal à bobigny parce
que ce tribunal a condamné des policiers
x alors ne lui plaît pas et qu'ils
considèrent qu'à ce moment là il s'agit
d'une mauvaise décision
il met en cause la magistrature eh bien
monsieur garde des sceaux permettez moi
de vous dire ceci avec finalement
beaucoup d'amitié nous regrettons qu'à
ce moment là
le garde des sceaux soit si silencieux
si je n'ai plus de demandes
d'explications de vote
donc nous avons sur ces trois
amendements de suppression que des avis
défavorables qui est pour adopter ces
trois amendements de suppression qui et
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés alors nous allons commencer
l'examen de vin amendements qui vont
pouvoir faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune et je donne tout de suite la
parole à jacques bizard qui nous
présente le 92 rectifier merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je crois pour aussi pour
être clair monsieur le ministre il
s'agit aucunement et d'ailleurs je ne
les ai jamais dit au cours de ce débat
que vous n'étiez pas le ministre qui
défend des les magistrats j'imagine mal
un garde des sceaux faisant le procès de
sa magistrature de la magistrature
mais nous avons parfaitement le droit de
considérer que ce texte est la volonté
de l'exécutif par ce texte c'est de
mettre en cause le travail qui est
réalisé par les magistrats
professionnels dans ce pays
or nous avons bien compris que vous
étiez là pour faire tirer le balancier
entre les propos excessifs qui viennent
d'être est excellemment rappelé par
notre collègue yannick du président de
l'exécutif
et puis cette nécessité
de respecter notre magistrature alors
cet amendement de suppression des alinéa
7 à 12 il vise bien évidemment la
création des citoyens assesseurs en leur
permettant de compléter le tribunal
correctionnel et la chambre des appels
correctionnels
le tribunal de l'application des peines
et la chambre de l'application des
peines de la cour d'appel
vous avez bien voulu reconnaître il y à
quelques minutes que c'est ce sixième ce
nouveau système cette nouvelle procédure
allait allonger les audiences que ça
allait coûter plus cher mais surtout je
crois que il faut aussi pouvoir dire que
les jurés moi je respecte profondément
les citoyens très attaché aux principes
traditionnels la république mais je ne
peux pas dire et je n'ai jamais dire que
les jurés soit la panacée
j'ai suffisamment plaidé de nombreuses
affaires dans les cours d'assises pour
avoir une opinion qui n'est peut-être
pas l'opinion générale et là aussi je
pense être fidèle à mes convictions
ceci étant en complétant le tribunal
correctionnel et la chambre et la
chambre des appels correctionnels
parce que vous auriez pu vous arrêter au
tribunal correctionnel non vous avez
rajouté des citoyens assesseurs à la
cour à la chambre des appels
correctionnels
puis vous en avez mis au tribunal
d'application des peines et à la chambre
d'application des peines or sur
l'application des peines
quel est le but là aussi soyons clair
monsieur le ministre quel est le but que
vous poursuivez c'est de répondre à des
interrogations des interpellations de
l'opinion par rapport à certaines
libération qui ont qui ont amené des
drames comme cela arrive
inéluctablement alors on peut toujours
pour faire mieux il n'en reste pas moins
que ce qui est dramatique c'est
d'utiliser ces drames de manière
médiatique pour aller systématiquement
dans un sens sécuritaire au lieu de
prendre les mesures adéquates
en ce qui concerne le tribunal
d'application des peines et surtout la
chambre d'application des peines il y a
la chambre d'application des peines
des représentants des personnes qui ne
sont pas des magistrats professionnels
qui ont une expérience qui ont une
compétence et vous allez les remplacer
par des citoyens assesseurs sans aucune
formation
est ce que au moins vous aurez vous
donnerez une formation à ces hommes et à
ces femmes sur ce qu'est la prison sur
ce qu'est véritablement le processus de
réinsertion
et sinon comment vont ils faire pour
avoir une opinion qui tiennent debout et
qui aille dans le sens de la justice et
d'une meilleure réinsertion
là encore la suppression de ces alinéas
s'impose alors merci jacques mézard qui
propose de supprimer les alinéas 7 à 12
et il est rejoint en cela par alain
anziani qui nous propose la suppression
de l'alinéa 9 oui pour les problèmes
émotifs monsieur le président mais pas
aussi un motif un peu différent est ce
que nous avons tous bien conscience que
ce qui nous est proposé change la nature
profonde de la procédure d'audience
devant le tribunal correctionnel
aujourd'hui procédure que nous
connaissons bien avec un des magistrats
devant le tribunal correctionnel qui
possède totalement leur dossier parce
qu'ils ont potassé le dossier avant
l'audience il ya des avocats qui ont
également pu avoir accès au dossier
il ya là des gens dont qui connaissent
la totalité des pièces des témoignages
des expertises l'ensemble des
déclarations demain avec le système qui
nous est proposé nous allons changer de
système et on va vers un système au fond
de l'oralité
il faudra que le président
lisa certain nombre de papiers il faudra
que les jurés citoyens demandent des
explications ils pourront même paraît-il
pouvoir accéder aux pièces enfin on voit
bien quand même la conséquence est tous
assez le temps et la difficulté c'est
que justement nos justice surchargée
aujourd'hui manque de temps la justice
surchargée manque de temps et vous allez
lui imposer encore des délais plus longs
à l'évidence le grand perdant de toute
cette procédure ces justiciables
merci alors nous poursuivons qui est ce
qui nous présente l'amendement numéro 5
toujours alain anziani et c'est même un
nom non appliqué cette fois ci à
l'application des peines moi je voudrais
appeler tous nos collègues sur les bancs
nous avons ensemble conduit un débat
extrêmement difficile en même temps
extrêmement constructif lors de la
discussion de la loi pénitentiaire et
notamment avec jean rené lecerf que nous
avons salué que je salue encore pour
l'apport qui a été considérable dans ce
débat à tel point qu'on a même pu parler
d'une loi le cers
bien qu'elle était un des objets précis
de cette loi à des objets précise cette
loi c'était justement essayer de faire
en sorte que la prison soit aussi non
seulement un lieu de répression de
sanctions elle doit l'être mais qu' elle
soit aussi un lieu de préparation à la
réinsertion et que évidemment à des
outils la réinsertion c'est
l'application des peines
la libération conditionnelle voilà le
sens des choses ce que vous nous
proposez c'est à dire tout d'un coup de
maître dans le circuit des jurés
citoyens
est-ce que cela va aller dans le même
sens d'abord c'est au fond une critique
implicite
si vous modifiez le système aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ne fonctionne pas en
revanche je demande à monsieur le
rapporteur qui a tellement suivi les
débats est ce qu'aujourd'hui notre
juridiction de l'apic sur des peines ne
fonctionne pas est ce qu'elle est
dangereuse pour le citoyen est ce
qu'elle ne donne pas des résultats
satisfaisants
pour la personne qui a été condamné
c'est à partir de là faisant il ya une
stick faisons une évaluation et voyons
ce qui est nécessaire en l'état je ne
vois pas l'intérêt du jury citoyen si ce
n'est on le sait quand même pourquoi on
se cache la vérité à chaque fois eh bien
on le sait c'est que l'idée qu' une
telle personne remise en liberté qui
effectivement eu un cas de récidive
alors là pour ce cas là on va modifier
l'ensemble du système nous prenons un
risque qui nous a un aussi un risque
tout à fait inutile mais harris très
important puisque c'est mettre en péril
la réinsertion des personnes qui demain
de toute façon retrouveront la liberté
merci alors qu'ils nous présentent
l'amendement numéro 6 jean-pierre michel
ai parlé tout à l'heure par cet
amendement nous demandons que les
citoyens assesseurs soit désigné
exactement comme les jurés d'assises et
que l'on applique à la chambre
correctionnelle l'approché de récusation
tels que ceux qu'elle s'appuie dans les
cours d'assises voilà et qu'on aille pas
après choisir comme c'est d'ailleurs sur
quels critères
parmi ces jurés d'un 6e qui pourrait
être assesseurs en correctionnelle et
ceux qui ne seraient que j'allais dire
jurés d'assises car on voit alors je
poserai également une question monsieur
le garde des sceaux qui annexe
est-ce qu'il prévoit 38 un décret
peut-être une circulaire je n'en sais
rien ou un arrêté pour augmenter le
nombre des jurés dans chaque département
car il va falloir aujourd'hui dans le
nombre que l'on connaît avoir enfin
pouvoir composer les cours d'assises
ce qui n'est pas si simple en même temps
avoir parmi eux ceux qui siégeront en
correctionnelle ce qu'ils changeront
pour le tribunal pour enfants de 7 à 18
ans et ceux qui siègeront pour les juges
d'application des peines
alors quand on voit la difficulté
aujourd'hui pour avoir les jurés
d'assises présent faut aller chercher
quelques fois chez eux et les a menés
est ce que vous allez augmenter le
nombre des jurés fait de la liste comme
on dit dans chaque département merci
jean pierre michel
alors maintenant c'est jacques mézard
qui a un crédit de 27 minutes pour neuf
amendements mais vous pouvez nous
présenter les amendements globalement
vous avez la parole même moment il selon
vous en revanche ça ne trompe pas oui je
je défendrai en même temps par souci de
cohérence les abandons de 93 à 97
ces cinq amendements dont certains
coordination ont trait aux dispositions
relatives à l'établissement des listes
de citoyens assesseurs
si l'on reprend l'étude d'impact la mise
en oeuvre du dispositif de ses citoyens
assesseurs nécessitera la mobilisation
de 80 de 9000 personnes supplémentaires
par an sur l'ensemble du territoire
toutes juridictions confondues c'est à
dire 50 4400 vacation tous les musées
tous les magistrats vous le diront à
condition de les entendre
il est aujourd'hui avec le système
actuel sur les jurés d'assises très
complexe de satisfaire aux besoins en
jurés d'assises soit près de 25000
personnes par an
on ne compte plus le nombre de personnes
tirées au sort qui cherchent tous les
prétextes possibles pour échapper à
leurs obligations de siéger et dont le
manquement pour motif légitime et est
puni par une amende recherche des
certificats médicaux toutes ses excuses
c'est un nombre très important et nous
le vivons depuis des années et on peut
d'ailleurs comprendre ces personnes par
exemple au vu de la faible
indemnisations journalières qui leur est
versé au delà du souci de contribuer au
service de la justice
quoi qu'il en soit les mêmes causes
appelle les mêmes effets et assurer un
chiffre de 9 mille citoyens assesseurs
par an c'est mobiliser deux à trois fois
plus de personnes par tirage au sort ce
qui apparaît presque impossible au bout
de quelques années de mise en oeuvre
nous pensons particulièrement aux
tribunaux correctionnels siégeant dans
le même ressort qu'une
d'appel d'autre part je rappelle que la
commission des lois et c'est heureux à
supprimer le dispositif initial du
projet de loi pour l'article 10 4 qui
consistait à dresser à la personne un
questionnaire où elles établissent et
cette personne elle même sa moralité
vous me direz comme ça on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi même
il est néanmoins anormal que le
parlement ne puisse connaître au minimum
du contenu des informations destinées à
être cueillies parallèlement la seule
journée de formation initiale prévue
pour les citoyens assesseurs sera très
insuffisante
une seule journée qui va assurer cette
formation pour quel coût avec 158
tribunaux correctionnels siège en 52
semaines par an la formation des
citoyens assesseurs nécessitera 8200
journée de travail au détriment des
fonctions de jugement et il eût été sans
doute préférable d'organiser des
formations de façon spécifique pour
chaque type d'intervention susceptible
de concerner les citoyens assesseurs
donc nous avons là encore la
démonstration de la précipitation avec
laquelle fut élaboré ce texte ce qui
risque d'aboutir à un monstre juridique
impraticable qui va dérégler un système
judiciaire qui n'en n'a aucunement
besoin
voilà donc le vous avez présenté 93 à 97
le 81,18 rectifier vous en avez encore
quatre en ce qui concerne monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre les
amendements 98 et 99 à ces deux
amendements visent à supprimer les
articles 17 et 18 nouveaux qui fixe les
conditions dans lesquelles sont affectés
les citoyens assesseurs
cette compétence d'affectation relèvera
du président de la juridiction chargée
dé dicter des ordonnances de roulement
bien entendu ça va être pour ce
président une charge particulièrement
lourde dans la mesure où contrairement
aux cours d'assises
les tribunaux correctionnels siège toute
l'année les chefs de cour n'ont pas
besoin de cette charge nouvelle d'autant
qu' aucune aide d'aucune compensation
n'est prévue
rien n'est dit sur les modalités de
convocation des citoyens assesseurs
alors que la non présentation est
civilement répréhensibles il faut le
rappeler
or là aussi et l'envoi de lettres
recommandées aura un coot quel sera le
résultat au final ralentissement de la
procédure nous l'avons déjà dit
désorganisation de la cour surtout en
fin de session et il eût été plus utile
de mobiliser les 8 millions d'euros de
fonctionnement que coûte cette réforme
en année pleine pour recruter des
greffiers dont on sait qu'ils font
cruellement défaut et il sera très
difficile de trouver le nombre de
citoyens assesseurs suffisant en
particulier quand les débats vont être
amenée à durer ou seront appelés des
citoyens supplémentaire puisque nous
avons tous dit et vous aussi monsieur le
ministre que ces audiences allait durer
beaucoup plus longtemps et je rappelle
que ces citoyens assesseurs normalement
ils devront ça ils pourront faire cela
huit jours dans l'année c'est à dire que
c'est un système d'une complexité
terrible beaucoup plus complexe en
réalité que le système des jurés
d'assises et qui va déséquilibrer et
poser des problèmes de fonctionnement
considérable à nos juridictions alors
l'amendement il vous reste l'amendement
sens et l'amendement singles rectifier
merci monsieur le président les allant
dans ce sens et sans sur l'article 1er
toujours soulève une nouvelle fois son
avant de suppression la question 1 de la
disponibilité de ses citoyens assesseurs
la commission et nous en convenons a
partiellement tenter de pallier cette
difficulté en abaissant de 23 à 18 ans
l'âge à partir duquel on peut être tiré
au sort mais nous doutons que si une
telle modification suffisent
d'abord parce que ne peut être citoyens
assesseurs se
lui qui a exercé cette fonction durant
les cinq années précédentes
ensuite parce que peuvent prétendre à 10
pensent les personnes de plus de 70 ans
alors que les retraités sont en général
les personnes les plus disponibles
plus généralement tous donnent
l'impression qu'à aucun moment n'a été
posée lors de la rédaction
la question de l'essence même de la
notion de jurys populaires car cet
acquis dont on peut discuter peut
difficilement être remis en cause
s'agissant des assises
néanmoins jugé son prochain et nous
l'avons rappelé n'est pas une tâche
anodine qui relèverait d'un simple
devoir citoyen il y a un impact un
impact psychologique il suffit d'avoir
assisté à des audiences de cour
d'assises pour se rendre compte de la
dureté de ses audiences de la difficulté
de ces audiences notamment lorsqu'un
juré est appelé à connaître d'une
affaire qui peut avoir pour lui une
résonance personnel on sort rarement
indemne d'une selle d'une telle
expérience
qu'il s'agisse de juger un crime
aujourd'hui ou de juger un crime demain
donc faire passer le jus gérer le juré
populaire
à ce stade deux citoyens assesseurs fait
disparaître tout ce qui fait l'essence
du juré d'assises
c'est-à-dire lé intime conviction
si les citoyens assesseurs doivent
connaître demain entre six et dix
dossiers par audience on nous a dit
peut-être plus tôt 4 c'est-à-dire siégé
huit heures d'affilée
il est évident que la vie d'amy gilles
des magistrats sera prééminent a
fortiori sur les matières les plus
techniques
tout concourt donc à enrayer ce que
devrait être la sérénité de la justice
elle est certes imparfaite mais ce n'est
pas une obligation de la rendre plus
imparfaite
si jacques mézard yves détraigne nous
présente le 152 rectifié bis
oui monsieur le président il s'agit d'un
amendement qui vise à éviter la
dispersion du citoyen assesseur entre
divers types de juridiction sur les huit
jours pendant lesquels il va être
mobilisée donc l'amendement vise à ce
que le citoyen ne puisse pas participer
sur ces huit jours alternativement des
juridictions de jugement ou à des juges
à des juridictions traitant de
l'application des peines ou encore un
tribunal correctionnel pour mineurs
si j'osais je dirais qu'il s'agit de
viser l'efficacité maximale et à
rentabiliser l'utilisation du citoyen
assesseur mer c'est lassant d'heure et
cliff y ait chaque bizarre vous en avez
encore un certain nombre 5
monsieur le président un sionisme et
chers collègues sur la maintenance en
deux il s'agit d'un amendement de
suppression de l'alinéa 44 dont nous
demandons la suppression car il impose
aux citoyens assesseurs de prêter
serment de bien et fidèlement remplir
leur fonction est de conserver le secret
des délibérations
on reviendra sur cette question du
serment à l'occasion de l'examen de
l'article 3 pour l'heure nous nous
étonnons que ce serment soit à quelques
nuances près le même que celui qui prête
les juges de proximité et les assesseurs
des tribunaux pour enfants
or ces deux catégories d'assesseurs sont
recrutés sur des critères stricts précis
et présente des garanties de formation
d'expérience bien plus importantes qu'un
simple citoyen et le mot simple citoyen
monsieur miss n'a strictement rien de
péjoratif qui n'a été que tirés au sort
nous défendrons donc à l'article 3 un
amendement établissant un dispositif
mieux adaptée en attendant la
suppression de cet alinéa s'impose sur
l'amendement 104 qui propose la
suppression des alinéas 45 à 48
c'est le problème de la récusation qui
vise par essence à garantir
l'impartialité objective et apparente de
la juridiction de jugement en cour
d'assises
elle est ouverte au ministère public et
à l'accusé qui peuvent en faire usage
sans motivation tout autre et le système
qui est ici proposée puisque les motifs
et les conditions de récusation
applicable aux citoyens assesseurs sont
celles valant pour les magistrats
limitativement listées à l'article 6 168
du code de procédure pénale or les
magistrats ont été formés pour juger
présente par nature des garanties
d'indépendance renforcée ils connaissent
le droit et peuvent naturellement se
déporter en cas d'incompatibilité
on ne peut transposer ce raisonnement
pour des citoyens étrangers aux arcanes
du droit et qui peuvent sans malice ne
pas se déporter par eux mêmes en tout
état de cause il faut être cohérent
aller au bout de la logique garantir
l'impartialité de la formation de
jugement en instaurant un véritable
système de récusation et je pense en
particulier aux ressorts des tribunaux
les plus petits ou bien évidemment là il
risque d'y avoir des problèmes
extrêmement important par rapport au
fait que dans nombre de villes moyennes
tout le monde se connaît même si cela
prend du temps il faut ce système de
récusation
on sent abstenant on prend des risques
et manifestement là aussi on va au
devant de graves difficultés
or nous poursuivons avec le 106 rectifié
président
pardon sans ça c'est un amendement de
repli qui fait suite à l'amendement 104
par lequel nous proposons la mise en
place d'un vrai système de récusation
comme je viens de l'indiquer qui est
largement inspiré par celui en vigueur
devant la cour d'assises et qui n'est
pas ouvert à la victime contrairement à
l'article 10 12 le problème de la
réalisation est en effet un problème
extrêmement important et je l' ai déjà
dit tout à l'heure
surtout dans les juridictions dans les
petites et moyennes juridiction en ce
qui concerne l'amendement 106 qui vise à
supprimer la linea 49,7 en ce qui
concerne cet alinéa
nous avons approuvé la modification
apportée par la commission mais le texte
initial de l'article 10 13 instituts est
en contravention de cinquième classe
punie de 1500 euros damende l' absence
non justifiée ou illégitime d'un citoyen
assesseur convoqué et là un minimum de
cohérence est en effet indispensable dès
lors que la même absence
s'agissant d'un juré d'assises est
constitutif d'une amende civile de 3750
euros
mais la commission réduit aller plus
loin et supprimer l'article 10 13 en
entier c'est en tout cas ce que nous
pensons car exercé les fonctions de
citoyens assesseurs serait un devoir
civique et 7 alinéa et surtout une pure
déclaration symbolique à portée
normative en ces temps où de nombreuses
catégories d'intérêt revendique sans
arrêt de nouveaux droits au détriment de
l'intérêt général
il convient de ne pas affaiblir la
portée de la notion de devoir en
l'utilisant de façon déraisonnable ou
inappropriés comme ici et à notre sens
il convient de revenir à l'esprit de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme dont
le préambule et non ce que cette
déclaration constamment présente à tous
les membres du corps social leur
rappelle sens
est-ce leurs droits et leurs devoirs en
d'autres termes il convient de cultiver
la parcimonie
merci le sens est rectifié alors le sens
est ce monsieur le président il s'agit
de supprimer les alliés à 50 à 53 il
s'agit d'un amendement de pure
coordination et maintenant je demandais
à yves détraigne de nous présenter le 5
nov rectifier merci à chefferie dans le
même esprit que l'amendement 152 que je
vous présentais il y à quelques minutes
l'amendement son 49e rectifié vise
j'allais dire à aller à l'efficacité
optimum avec les citoyens assesseurs et
donc je vous propose qu'ils bénéficient
non pas d'une simple information sur la
fonction qui vont exercer mais plutôt
d'une formation de telle sorte qu ils
soient plus efficaces dans les fonctions
qu'on leur demande d'exercer écoutez
nous avons présenté quoi tous ces
amendements ont été présentés de toute
évidence ce sera très difficile d'avoir
l'ensemble de l'avis des rapporteurs et
de monsieur le ministre
donc nous allons nous plus les
explications de votre nous allons nous
arrêter
ici c'est la fin de cette séance merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr très
belle journée à tous